check one two three hello hello hello
hello hello
hello hello
hi hello
check one two three
one two three one two three one two
three
one two three
one two three
one two three hello hello am i here why
don't i see myself hello
one two three
one two three one two three one two
three
[Music]
check one two three
one two three check hello
oh there i am hi how's it going good to
see you all thank you so much for
joining me
i'm going to die a lot i'm going to be
playing
hello
elden ring there it is i'm gonna be
playing elden ring and uh
i don't imagine i'm gonna be doing too
good i probably
should
put myself down
here
probably you guys like the thumbnail i
spent like 45 minutes making that
thumbnail
and my photoshop crashed in the middle
of making it and didn't save uh because
of course i wasn't saving as i was going
and i didn't expect to be working that
long like photoshop couldn't handle
the bulbous nature of what i was
creating
um
but anyway hello hi sorry the music's
probably very loud
so today i'm going to be playing a
little bit of elden ring this is not the
start of a series because this game is
apparently way too large to do a series
of but today
cloak
has an elden ring collab if you couldn't
tell
by my backwards shirt
we have an elden ring
uh
collab link in the description that does
say tarnished it's backwards i swear
it's not bad i'll fix it hang on
you guys don't would never believe me
bam see
elden ring
cloak
tarnished and on the back there's
stuff
so anyway if you guys want to check out
some of the elden ring uh stuff we got
there's a link in the description go to
cloakbrand.com
cloakbrand.com
not dot dom
not that anyway uh go check it out if
you'd like it's pretty cool it's
actually some of the cool stuff that
i've seen um but i'm gonna be playing
elden ring um now i don't play a lot of
the souls games but i have played
bloodborne like through and through and
i played a little bit of dark souls 3.
i'm not great at them i'm not going to
claim to be great at them just like i'm
not going to claim to be great at a lot
of these games uh and i've actually
already started because i don't want to
go through the oh i don't want to go
through the
the tutorial section
pick the samurai everyone picks a
samurai i i don't care it's whatever
like it doesn't matter to me it is what
it is and it will be what it will be
it's it's just fine
there's something wrong with my mic
is something wrong with my audio
is everything fine
is everything fine
yeah i was gonna like okay so i played
this a little bit on my own because i
didn't want to walk into the stream and
just be absolutely garbage at it which
is what i'm gonna be anyway so don't you
worry about that let me be the garbage
that i am and you just observe as the
garbage
that is this being
attempts to play this game and be
garbage at it i'm not going to play far
i've got one objective in this stream
one objective only
is number one to tell you about cloak
and eldon rings collab but number two
this horse
[ __ ]
that guy right no that guy right there
i'ma kick his ass i am a new character
i think i'm playing
i don't know i just picked the first one
i think it's uh no that's not right
this is gonna be this could be painful
uh
this is pongo um he's uh
i believe he's a vagabond
i'm not a hundred percent sure but i'm
gonna kick that horse's ass and it just
so happens that there's a person on the
horse but i'm gonna kick the horse's ass
that's my objective
something wrong with my
no
no it's fine
so yeah you all get to you're shaking
and you're crying you check the link in
the description below you go listen to
go my favorite sports team you go listen
to distractible whatever
i'm gonna kick this thing's ass
observe as i
remember how to play
okay let's swing a strong attack
shieldy perry i'm never gonna use that
jumping was there always jumping
in this game before was there always
jumping because i don't remember there
ever being jumping
and that's kind of throwing me a little
bit
i'm not muted you can't lie to me i know
the truth
i see beyond the realm that you
understand you don't know
what i am and who i be
so just let me hold on jumping no no
yeah
not easy jumping right there was like
that weird hop jumping and it seems a
lot more mobile in this game
which is cool i like the open world
aspect of it but also when i was playing
on my own i started out as a wretched
which is the naked dude with the club
and that's why the name is pongo but i
thought that it might not be too good
and you see my uh you can see in the
distance between those poles there that
uh i've got
that's where i died before because i've
been trying to get good at beating this
guy i'm not muted
i'm not
i know what i'm saying here i'll trick
you one two three one two three one two
three one two three one two three one
two three one two three one two three
one two three one two three
one two three one two three one two
three one two three
and therefore
you all will know
you see
see chat you have exposed yourself why
am i saying one two three because you
can hear me
and now i'm going to kick this thing's
ass wait hold on
okay
uh where's my there we go oh what is
this
oh that's nice
all right let's not uh okay
you guys
you shush you shush
you shush
you shush
i am a pro gamer professional hey
berries
i'm a pro gamer
and i'm gonna beat this thing into the
ground
you just wait okay hang on dodge
i don't know anything about the game but
it's very pretty
and i've only explored a little bit
and this is a new character that i
started just for the express purpose of
kicking your ass
come here [ __ ]
i'm gonna show you what for oh
oh my god oh my god
yeah yeah you want somebody
okay that hurts
all right hold on hold on
yeah i missed me [ __ ] what do you think
of this
shot right up your horse's butt
all right i got a shield i should use it
oh that's not good
ah
no
up the ass all right okay
yeah come at me bro missed me
where are you yo
oh
that don't look good come here
ah miss me oh backswing
all right my my thing don't have much
range here
come here oh yeah
that's what you get
missed me ow hit me you hit me
all right you hit me
i'm not gonna lie you hit me
you got me there
but uh
listen i was just going easy on you i'm
gonna
show you what for next time
hold on hold on everybody you're you're
not you're not paying attention remember
cloak elden ring cloak got the sweet
elden ring collab that's why i'm here
there's a link in the description
and uh
you should definitely check it out if
you want some of this sweet
sweet sweet elden ring clothing all
right i think my charge straight in
strategy definitely worked
what you doing
man that's a slow attack because you're
a [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
um
missed me
oh
ah backswing
he does a lot of accidents
y'all
oh missed me
up hey yes oh yeah
pull out that one oh
okay all right
hold on
now see see how you use a [ __ ]
you see that i'm gonna i'm gonna rectify
that
right up your rectum
i'm gonna
hold on okay i gotta use my shield more
because i'm getting
that guy wallops that guy really wallops
you
okay really waltz yeah this is my only
objective today in this stream
i'm gonna kick this guy's ass maybe i'll
maybe it's because he has the high
ground
i'll try to draw him out to a little
lower hey
hey
your horse is fat come at me come
come come i dare you mist
man this sword is uh
not long oh god use the shield i keep
saying i will and i don't
what are you doing
ah this the shield doesn't do nearly as
much as i was hoping
oh i jumped over you [ __ ]
ow okay that very painful i missed
y'all
okay
all right hold up
i notice how i said that i would use my
shield more and then i used it once i'm
going to use it twice this time i'll use
it twice
sweet cloak elden ring collab
check it out
it's golden luminescent and it'll make
you better at the game
garen not guaranteed not legally
it won't legally make you better at the
game but it will completely illegally
i if i can hear lawyers like at home
just their heads
exploding
all right come here come
you may have the high ground
but your rotundity will draw you ever
closer to me i'm crouching i don't want
to crouch
i want to boldly go i see he's scared
now he knows i'm going to use my shield
definitely
[Music]
wow you suck oh he doesn't suck
all right all right okay okay
ah
oh two
that's unfair
oh i thought i was dead
okay hold on hold on
hold on
every time i die i get to do a sweet
cloak promo through the link in the
description below guaranteed to not make
you better at the game
guaranteed
all right [ __ ]
get ready to get a new [ __ ]
i'm bad at smackdoc i'm i'm not gonna
lie now let me pick up my zero what are
they they're not souls in this game what
are they
all right you may have the high ground
but i'll take it from you
all ground is higher if you well you
can't oh he can hit me from there
yeah
haha fools on you i missed
yeah
oh you can't hit me with your horse
that's unfair
oh shield right my shield i keep
forgetting oh
oh
ha backswing my shield is effective
oh
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing [ __ ]
miss me
kiss me
you kind of suck
not gonna lie you're trash
oh
come here shield right i have a shield
come here
oh
all right all right all right shield
right god i keep forgetting
oh
three
four
five
miss me
you thought that was panic so that was
my battle shout
oh god wow
well i'm out of potions which makes it a
fair fight
two
he keeps doing those two hits
and sometimes
five all right
shield right
i don't i'm not good at parrying can you
parry this guy i doubt it i'm not gonna
try
all right take two this is only the
second try
berries
come here you
come here you sack of golden [ __ ]
oh god colloquial
link in the description all right come
here you come here you come here you
come here yeah he's shaking and crying
right now he knows what he's up against
shield right
oh no
oh two a three
oh
shield
can't hit what you can't see [ __ ]
came back
all right
i keep hitting him on his left side what
if i hit him on his or his i keep
hitting him on his right side what if i
hit him
on his left side where he has the shield
i doubt he uses it
if i'm not using my shield i doubt he
even understands what a shield is no
varies all right second try
clock l didn't ring link in the
description
all right [ __ ] you come here i'm gonna
show you a thing or two about a thing or
two
you're vulnerable right flank it's only
protected by a gigantic shield huh i was
late on that where are you taking me sir
oh
okay he really wants to only show me his
other side i can't see a thing hi
where am i what i'm inside the horse
for warmth
come to me
oh you're too slow
i'm i'm aware of your back swings now
oh
you got another one you do i'm out of
stamina
ow
all right shield right that's a two
swing no it's not interesting
oh
uh
don't mind me
ah he does the two sometimes oh
okay
all right listen
listen
listen
listen
all right
listen
you listening
i'll tell you next time all right sweet
cloak
i'm gonna channel the power of this
cloak as you can see
this uh
cloak eric's cloak elden ring collab
really enhances my power
does the screaming help i mean obviously
you can see this is only my second try
i'll only pick up my zero souls
all right it's me again
i didn't hear no bell oh god
that was late
or early oh your shoulder
oh
that's very painful oh i shouldn't heal
now
shield
right i have a shield i keep
forgetting
and i have a shield
all right hold on
let me get this guy i'm gonna get this
guy think up uh some names to call him
some insults
well you you get you you and your your
yellow armor you you piss armor piss
baby
you you compensating with that horse huh
huh
oh big axe yeah i'm sure that's not
making up for something do you lack
sneak attack
oh god late early aha but i still got oh
god the shoulder's a little rude
not gonna lie
ha vulnerable side
aha
he doesn't like me on that side come
here wow
can't shoulder what you can't see that's
a big horse
ow
all right shield right i have a shoe
oh
oh the shield did nothing the shield did
nothing
i must not have been shielding properly
hold on
hold on
hold on
hold on opposite of good armor that's
good he gave me the shoulder i'll give
him
the shoulder
i'll i'll get in the comp standing for
stuff
get better gear nah i got the best gear
best gear in the game
i'm uh max level i'm maxed out
come here you come here you
i'ma show you a thing or two about a
thing or two
wow
once again too early oh
what you hitting there nothing
yeah
oh
try me [ __ ]
oh what are you hitting it's because
he's got the high ground that's what it
is come here you oh
come here come here knocking down trees
you eco terrorists
come here are you
oh god oh
oh my shield [ __ ]
that's what you get oh
oh ow
all right all right oh
you caught me drinking he caught me
drinking there's a universal rule about
not hitting someone when he's drinking a
flask
all right you
you you there no no no this is my only
objective this stream is beating this
guy
he's the first boss well technically
there's the other boss in the opening of
the game but this is the first boss
anyone that doesn't face this guy
head-on is a coward and i'm calling you
out if you go around this guy you're a
coward this is the first boss oh you
think you're two you think you're too
weak at this point you gotta get better
gear nah you just gotta get better
that's the thing you gotta look inside
yourself and question who you are if
you're skipping this guy
this guy's here and you gotta face him
down if you want the elder ring you you
you deserve that [ __ ] you gotta beat
this guy this guy's the first guy that's
gonna call you a pansy whoa
take my shield
yeah that's what i thought that's what i
thought
that's what i thought oh
come here you
stop destroying the forest
oh miss me
i missed you
oh oh my god this guy is this this sword
is not
doing what i want it to well that's okay
it's the best sword in the game
yeah come here are you
oh no you're gonna hit oh
my god
i was in mid dodge oh did i accidentally
jump oh oops i think i jumped so he
could properly slice me in half
how dare you try to slice in the sweet
cloak elden ring collab
available through the link in the
description below
all right take two
stick two guys oh good raining it can
wash away your tears when i beat the
[ __ ] out of you
come here you oh you think you're so
tough i'm still standing
i'm still standing
come here you
come here
yeah uh-huh watch this move oh
okay you dodged it
oh
i don't know why how
shield oh
come here
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
oh the two
all right
i went easy on you that time i went easy
on you
all right so i've learned everything i'm
now calculating all the lessons that
i've learned from uh
taking the fight to this guy i've let
him win many times so that i could see
through his strategy and uh formulate a
proper plan that's going to allow me to
really
put the hurt on them and now on this
second try i'm gonna i'm gonna show them
what fur i'm gonna show them what fur
hey why don't you go uh kill some more
trees i'm here to protect uh why don't
you go fight that big tree huh the only
thing you can win against something that
can't fight back like me but shut up
also i hate you
i'm coming for you [ __ ]
oh god
what are you doing nothing
oh
can't do nothing can't do nothing oh
oh i was supposed to dodge and i didn't
oh my god
why do we keep dodging i'm like i'm like
those alien uh the guys in prometheus
when you know the ship is like rolling
straight this way and they're just
running in a straight line i should
dodge
sideways
shield right i forgot about this shield
all right
that was just the first try guys on this
the second try i'm really gonna wallop
them i'm really gonna give them the old
walloping treatment here
this is for all the cowards that skipped
by you
the real
what are we tarnished
we don't we don't run away from a fight
yeah yeah you think you think you don't
you shouldn't you shouldn't oh what's
that a miss yep it was on my first
shield
not today
oh yeah
right up the butt right up the butt i
got greedy miss me
oh something
where are you
miss me
miss me
you miss me
but not this
oh god
okay all right okay you haven't hit me
kind of because you suck isn't it oh oh
god
i did the same thing i keep doing that
i'm really
prometheline away
anyway
i meant to do that i could tell that he
was having a bad day so i decided to let
him win that round
yeah i can tell when people are hurting
when all their life is uh crumbling
around them and that guy is just the
saddest sack of [ __ ] i've ever seen in
my hey berries but on this second try
here i'm really gonna give them the give
them the good stuff you know doesn't
matter how sad and depressing your life
is horse man
you gotta face the face your doom
sometime i'll get the high ground what
are you gonna do i'm on a rock
yeah uh-huh i bet you didn't expect this
oh
ah
miss me
i'm behind you i'm in front of you i'm
everywhere and in between
oh backswing right shield
missed me
that was a lie but you know
it felt right
real cute real cute buddy
y'all
real cute
ow
miss me
right in the ass
yeah uh-huh
now on this second try i've decided to
not go so easy on you
how's it feel not playing on easy mode
anymore
that's what i thought
oh yeah this trick
a very cute
adorable even
okay watch this
hang on hold on hey your horse's butt
healed me i drank right from the shrink
oh
shield right i have a shield
whoa that was real cute
oh god what is that
well that was new okay apparently if
you're on that side of him he actually
figures out how to use the shield after
a bit
anyway
i could tell that he started weeping
halfway through that fight and i have
such a kind heart that i decided that i
wasn't gonna go home like take a fight
to him i was gonna let him win that one
he started begging and pleading me
mid-fight you know just because he was
like i'm so pathetic and you know all my
friends are gonna be mad if you beat me
and i was like you know i'm so nice
i decided to let him have that win
anywho all right second try though i'm
really gonna get cloaked elden ring link
in the description below you want some
sweet elven ring clothing oh go to
cloakbrand.com
all right oh come here he can't find me
on it um oh yeah he found me
i got my shield unlocked this time this
is a problem
come here you
shield that's what they call the shield
you ever heard of it ow
i don't understand
you miss me
i did not miss you
yeah
that sphinct is really getting away from
me
yo
oh come here you
you keep getting the high ground it will
do you no good
all right that one was my bad you know
every other death up until this point
was not my fault and if it was it was
intentional that one you know everyone
makes a mistake every once in a while he
i took him i i i took him uh easy i took
easy on him i i was easy on him i took
ease on him i eased him on
that was easy on him this one
you're about to get a you're about to
get a shrinked full sword if you know
what i'm talking about ooh zero
come here you
come here you come here you come here
i'm too fast his eyes can't perceive my
movement
gotta stop moving this guy really likes
moving
wow
uh what about this
shield right
oh she'll
miss me i'm in the shrinked
ow no shield there i didn't ha ha
now watch this
i'm unkillable
you cannot kill me oh
i would love to be able to see him
well your first mistake was letting me
live
your second mistake was not dying in
time
oh
yo uh
it's all misunderstanding
all right i'm just gonna
preemptively
what about this other weapon i've never
used this
probably not a good idea to
try a new weapon mid-fight
i'll marry you a bit
yeah oops
all right i do not know this weapon
hi y'all
come on it's supposed to have reached
doesn't it
yeah
ah
oh you're lucky
you're lucky
you know why you're lucky because i'm
not even using my shield
come here come here come here
[Music]
up the butt
oh yeah that's what i call a poke
oh
yeah oh what
i swear i rolled
your
video he's jumping with joy he's jumping
with joy
i actually have no idea that might be
more helpful but honestly i think it
slows me down
so i think i'm gonna just stick with
yield uh sortie what happens if i
don't use can i dual wield ew
can i what if i okay whatever
what if i do one of these bad boys
would i be unstoppable
oh i'm unstoppable
i'm not quite uns oh
yeah
oh get it
oh he's done for now
he's done four
he's done four
oh you're done for come at me
come at me
you think you are going to beat this
this this
unshakeable
unflappable unstoppable god of a man
before you
come
come i dare you to come i want you to
come
come here
come to me that's right you're doomed
now
oh god
you think you've won
yeah
wow i did a lot of damage
come at me
you think you funked you thunk thronked
oh are you stumbled
ow
all right get ready for another
facebook oh
i was talking to myself
look at your health pathetic oh
nice try but try some of the oh
come hither
if you want to taste wish you don't
come hither
out
anyway
that does a lot of damage i'm actually
kind of shocked at that
unequip the halberd what do you mean
unequip the halberd unequipped
yeah you know what actually i'll go back
to you but i don't think you can you
can't do that sweet maneuver though yeah
let me
no oops i know what i'm doing
oh that's a sweet maneuver
that's pretty dope like the right spot
maybe i could switch off of the shield
not that the shield's doing me a lot of
good but if i use the shield you know
maybe mayhaps
come here hither
come to the
come wither come bither [ __ ]
come tither me [ __ ]
yeah uh-huh
but what about this
oh now
what about this oh what about this
oh
your horse's ass cannot avail you
your sphincter is no match for my might
the might of my sword
missed
missed
oh
oh oh you suck isn't there like some
kind of i i know that sound
there's like gotta be oh my god there's
no defending that
oh
joke's on you i healed
oh
shield right
oh
all right
sphincter it is
what how did that miss i feel i feel
cheated
i feel cheated it's a counter-strike
yeah how do i how do i do that i don't
even know how do you do the um
how do you do the
finishing thing how do you do that when
he goes down
what do you need to do is there a button
you need to press
i have no idea
what's the butt what's the button is it
like what is that what's this oh
no
r1 r1 but that's what i did
how do i do that
z r1 r2 hold rb r2 but these are
different things man okay what was that
you were saying about okay armband why
how do i two hand it someone said i
could two-hand
he's got a glowing spot
well he's such a dull piece of [ __ ] i
must not have noticed the glow
[Laughter]
all right anyway time to kick some ass
triangle oh triangle arm
interesting
oh you're going down now
oh get ready for a face
you can't hit my vulnerable backside
anymore
i'm coming for you [ __ ] i've got you
you missed
you missed again
oh
ha ha
you fail again
oh where's the glowy i don't see a glow
he's just so boring he doesn't even have
a glow
i missed oh
[Applause]
that's a little rude
okay okay here we go watch this
up the ass
oh
up the ass
okay i don't know where the where is
the thing
oh god
uh you and some of me
are your schwa
oh you're a little far i'm uh oh
i think i overused that ability
all right [ __ ]
you think you funked you oh
oh
all right
not today i can't do anything apparently
ow
you hurts but not enough oh
you
come at me
come i dare you to come
so what uh uh so why is this squared off
uh blacked out there did i do it too
much
did i do it
glow in the middle of the chest
it died
no mana
oh
that costs mana what am i some kind of a
wizard [ __ ] what am i some kind of a
fufu spell caster nah
no way
there's no way that costs mana i'm gonna
call that fighting spirit
i just i felt bad for him that's all it
was i felt too bad for him
fp fighting power that's what it is i
ain't no
lightning bolt wizard
ain't pathetic like that this guy
probably uses magic look at this guys
i'm a magic user yeah oh
wrong button i forgot how to play for a
second there ow
i mean i was pretending to be dead oh
take some of this oh okay where's this
glowing spot what do you mean there's no
glowing spot
you're lying to me
aha
you fell right into my trap
where's the glow there's no glowing spot
i think
there's no glowing spot
there's white dots but the white dot's
always on that's like my targeting
reticle anyway it doesn't matter i don't
need it you know i don't need it because
like i've said previously
magic
is for big babies and i am no baby
i am a man with a sweet cloak alden ring
collab and this seat there's a white dot
right there that ain't it that ain't it
come
come
ah you're scared to come aren't you
you shan't
try
i missed
i won't miss again i missed again
oh now
i'm only pretending to be hurt oh
you're
here
oh lag
i blame lag i blame the lag
it's perfectly valid to blame the lag
oh see
you are done and that was a well worth
strike
i forgot i i literally just whenever i
play this ice for some reason i i forget
how to play for like pizza time and i'll
be like what do the buttons do and i'll
i literally have no idea
come come your time is nigh oh
all right
unite your time
no
a battery backswing
that's not fair
you know
you all are saying that you need to
hit the light spot
i'm kicking his ass uh without that so i
think it's all good
i think it's all good
you silly silly fool
this silly fool all right second try who
berries i'm gonna get them this time
guys i'm gonna get them this time you
know why
i've got the power
of anime on my side you
thou shalt us not come
this
i was pretending
oh
okay let me try the old jump strategy
that definitely did the good damage
yeah uh-huh oh you mad you mad bro
ain't no oh that's what i thought you
were scared to do the finishing blow but
i am not
come here i'm running what are you gonna
do you can't hit what you can't see
[Music]
pathetic beautiful ah
that that's big
i meant to actually hit but i didn't
good morning good sir
how are you today
that shield hurts
anyway
all right okay this time i was just
playing with him
no
he's all mine
all
mine what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna run
down my foot
my foot ability when my fappable meter
goes down then i'll switch back is it
just like what is that
i have a mana abortion
he's done for
he's done my fap ability is unquenchable
thou shalt know the might of my faps
uh tricked ya
tricked ya
i will jump at
thee trick chicken
this is final battle
this is the last attempt this is the
second try
you are doomed before you even begun
ow
well
seems like you've got a few new
tricks up your sleeve but my fapable
meter is back to full
you'll never win
you'll never succeed oh
oh
i don't know where i am i'm just gonna
strike
and i'm gonna strike again
you think you funked you
this is your doom sir your doom
your doom good sir
your doom has come and its name is
markiplier
well all right then
oh so we're having this conversation
well that seemed excessive and i
appreciate your candor but next time
i shall show thee what it is
anyway that's i wanted to show it
ah it's fine guys closer matt it don't
matter because every time that i play
any boss like this it always gets down
and that wasn't even it it always gets
down to one hit
and that's when i die so that wasn't
even the most disappointing death get
ready to be more disappointed
but now that i know i have the power of
fap on my side
you
wouldn't dare to come
towards a man as fappable as i
my fap is overwhelming
behold the power
of my
fap i missed
but i shan't again
there's a big horse you got there oh
come back you're making me waste my fap
backswing
oh oh this seems like i should be
hitting you
do not
i meant to dodge but it's fine that was
my fap juice
that was oh
drank the wrong potion drank the wrong
potion there that's well
not what i meant
anyway
now i'm going to get you
that was just the first try guys by the
way a link in the description to the
sweet cloak elden ring collab you know
it you got it we got it
and this
huh
this time on the second try he's gonna
be so shaking and crying
he's practically quivering
he's undulating with terror
sheer
unadulterated
terror
look at my stance and look at you look
at me and then look at you
weep at the inadequacies that you feel
burning inside of you okay
you won't you shan't and you shout
[ __ ]
right up the ass and another one for
good i'm out of stamina but you you
would have it it would have that's what
it would have been like
ah i missed again this is just a teaser
trailer
oh
all right listen
i've gone easy on you
i'm gonna get serious if you keep up
keep this up
i'm coming
ah
i just wanted to taste
how did that hit me how did i understand
how that hit me but
all right
looks like i'm gonna have to try
this guy doesn't know what's coming for
him
don't you just feel bad for him he's
about to get a full taste of my power
this time
i'm really gonna give him the business
just you wait good sir just you wait
oh
are you approaching me
it looks like you're approaching me
now why would you do a silly thing like
that
the power
oh
missed [ __ ]
that's what it feels like to fail
what is it to me
no
nay i say
nay i say that's right run away
oh this is the moment
i
can't hit what you can't see
oh he hit
he saw me
oh
you think oh well
i meant to dodge
i intended to
i intended to
so therefore i am the victor because i
intended to dodge there
i am the winner
i win by default but i'll give you
another chance i'll give you another
fair chance here
i'll give you another chance
surrender now and i won't make this
embarrassing for you
uh ooh barry all right second try i'm
really gonna give him the business
really gonna give it to him
come here come to the
come
come
do you even speak english
i said come good sir
crippled with indecision i see
oh
hey wait a minute
that move went differently in my head
i keep missing and i don't intend to
oh
see i keep meaning to dodge and then i
don't
all right
it's time
give me your energy chat put your energy
in chat and you will empower me to beat
him
you will give me your strength not that
i need it not that i need it not not
saying i need it i'm actually only using
like 10 of my true potential but uh
just uh just know that uh i want you to
feel like you are a part of this and you
are you are a small part but
i uh want to
know that you're here
and if you're not here i can only assume
that you've clicked the link in the
description below and you are
looking at the sweet cloak elven ring
collab
on cloakbrand.com
ah
your first mistake
oh
oh i'm out of stamina that's right
that's what that does interesting
strategy sir being a [ __ ]
come here though tibber
ah trying to hide behind a tree it will
not avail you
nothing will avail you i barely even
know what a veil means
oh
ow i thought you got stunned on that one
for some reason turns out you did not
oh running away again
oh the backswing
i'm on your vulnerable side
hang on hold on no i say nay
oh god
ye gods
oh
oh you're open
you're open he's not open
[Laughter]
oh god anyway
this turns out he wasn't open guys i
thought
it was closed for business it turns out
no that was so funny to me anyway hey
fruit all right second try
let me get out uh you know i'll keep it
on the fat potion because
i'm not gonna need to heal he's not even
gonna hit me
come
come here
come here
yes yes yes very scary
what oh i did not mean to do that oh
you see how you are terrible and i am
incredible do you see this you see this
good set
missed by that much
oh okay i missed i wanted to show you
how much you missed by it was that
pathetic sir
oh
well i might want to switch this just a
moment
oh
god
god i forgot to dodge
it's a vital part of my strategy
yes
let's chug one of these down
oh
that shield though that shield though
wish i could do that wish i could do
that
but uh you know i don't need it it's
actually i've researched it extensively
it's uh it's a tactic in the book known
as how to be a giant [ __ ]
and uh it's kind of like the main lesson
is use that move so i don't want to do
that but it says a lot about you my dude
i don't know why i always want to hit
him right off the bat like that because
it never works out for me
but alas
i'm nothing if not persistent
just wanted to show you the pointy end
of my sword so you know which part
supposed to hit me idiot
come on come on come on
oh that hurt you my pride
nope
oh
i call that the backswing
sound familiar
i dodged i thought i funkled i funkled
that i dodged but turns out that i did
not
come here come to that cup with it
oh okay
fired it if i had hit half of the blows
that i've landed on you
you'd be really feeling the hurt at this
point
well i don't know why some dirt hurt me
that badly but
seems a little silly
you guys like my thumbnail i spent way
too long i spent like 45 minutes because
my photoshop crashed in the middle of
making it
anyway all right time to get serious
guys time to get serious by the way link
in the description to the uh cloak elden
ring collab you might want to check it
out only available for a limited time
and it's
really sweet as you can see how much
you can see the correlation between this
clothing and how much
gooder at this game that i be
i'm coming to you this time
why because you suck
oh
interesting strategy
[Laughter]
hold on guys hold on guys
hold on guys hold on guys
hold on
i think i'm just i'm just
i'm being a little silly at this point
i'm just
i'm not focusing i'm not going try hard
mode ooh a berry
so on my second try let's uh let's give
this yeah that didn't count that didn't
count i was i was taking the fight to
him which i'm gonna do again you you
scared scared potter
oh
what
he teleported
all right you know
i really would like one of these to
connect
hey walk into it he didn't
turns out he didn't
push you off the cliff and you die
you were supposed to fall off the cliff
and die to do not read the instructions
ah-ha under your backswing [ __ ]
i'm out of stamina you're
replenishing fap
and i was pretending
oh you're lucky the rock was in the way
oh
i was drinking sir
i wonder what would happen if i just
like
if i just went full rambo
because i keep trying to do this square
off move
i'm kind of curious i'm just gonna go
full rambo on him because
i'm kind of starting to realize he's
really slow
that's kind of the thing he's
he's really slow
hang on let me go rambo for a second
just let just uh humor me this one uh
this one's not second try this is just
uh this is a fake try hold on a second
okay he still hits you there okay
okay
i forgot i put on the shield so i could
use it i keep forgetting to use the
shield
i keep forgetting
i keep no no no no no i gotta go full
rambo
i got a full rambo in this [ __ ] hang on
hold on
hold on all right
all right
oh you missed
oh
yeah hit that tree yeah you scared
scared potter
you wouldn't
he's really slow
wait a minute
he's really slow
well also my game seems to be lagging
but he really seems kind of slow
am i crazy
he's really so well my game is super
lagging it i called him out and he's
he's quivering he's making that my
computer to shake
from the intensity of my
smack talk he couldn't possibly
he's
this guy's really slow
wait a minute
oh okay well your horse is faster than
you are [ __ ] but
he's
this isn't just me right
he's really slow
has he been like this the whole time
i feel like when i first started this
fight he was really a lot faster
oh what a hit
am i he's
is he slower
there's no way i'm not doing near as
much damage without my
sweet perry move or whatever it is
he's really slow
oh that was nuts well that was still
slow i
couldn't see where i was
this guy's kind of a [ __ ]
oh whoops
oh god that got me that guy's really
slow
if i hit him as many times as i was
hitting him with the powerful thing that
i did before
he'd be dead
am i crazy
he's really slow
hang on okay what was it was uh
oh [ __ ] what was the button to make me
dual hand it
well
i guess i could just do it this way what
was the button
what was the button there was a button
to make me dual handle
i don't remember help help what was it
help help
help
what was the button
triangle
no not triangle what was the button oh
oh our our plus string triangle plus one
there we go okay
not that i don't know if this helps or
not but whatever
anywho
come here you suck
i'm i'm just i'm i'm just really a
flower
was i not crazy
so if i just charge him
what was i panicking for
wow
he's really slow
oh that thing i just gotta run away when
that happens right
oh right the back swing of course
oh dodge
i i said in my head i went dodge in my
brain my hands did nothing i literally
went dodge
nothing came through
but yeah
he's totally be i mean i knew he was a
[ __ ] from the beginning i just didn't
realize the extent of how pathetic he
really was
okay anyway
i'm gonna do this
also
sweet cloak elden ring collab if you
want some
really
tarnished merch
go to cloakbrand.com link in the
description check it out for yourself hi
i was up
you uh missed me
oh come on
come on come on
i was gonna go ahead and re-up my fap
right now
uh-huh
that thing
where are you what are you oh that would
have oh god he's doing it again oh
god
you're not supposed to be able to do
that twice in a row
oh man yeah that shield is like a
one-hit ko no matter what but
very interesting very interesting very
interesting
all right second try guys
that was the first try
i think i've got his number what is that
the hell is that
what is that
oh oh
what is up my bros
oh
that [ __ ] of it hey i think we can all
agree that should have hit
oh missed by that much sir
pathetic really if you think about it
what are you doing
what was that move
what did you just do sir
your poor horse
tom here
uh-huh uh-huh i'm gonna rebuild my fat
levels oh he's doing the thing
ah missed me by that much
that really hurts
oh please
all right
you think
you thought wrong
[Music]
oh that's much longer range than i
previously suspected
ah under your guard
oh that was not
all right i got him i've discovered it
i've analyzed his weaknesses turns out
he's a [ __ ]
it turns out
check out cloak once i kill the arse i
shall oh don't worry
he's already dead
he's already dead
don't you worry
don't you worry about a thing
i've got him i've got him by the
balls
he's
he's already gone
rxt oh god
roar
oh i always forget about that backswing
[Laughter]
as you didn't see anything wipe your
memory of this and that didn't happen
that didn't happen it was it was my
punishment for saying rxd that's what
that's what that was and the just
punishment that was i was the punishment
fits the crime on that one though that
one was uh
it was no good that was no good yeah
that was the first try though that was
first try all right this time
got me that i want to fight him down on
this uh level area or maybe i'll just
take the high ground you couldn't
possibly win
because the high ground oh god
i got you in the rocks
ah
what do you think of that
what do you think what do you what thank
you of
that you tried and failed
that one was more successful
oh
you're white where am i where am i i'm
gonna hit you
and one more for good measure and i'm
gonna heal and then uh hop up
and now
we're doing it for real
now comes the truest test of all
ah what's that you suck i thought so oh
missed me
oh no you're terrible
and oh that's i almost forgot that that
was much longer range than oh
wow all right so you've still got a
twofist on you or something like that
oh
what's that a [ __ ]
so it comes down to this
goodbye
yeah
[Music]
um
and only on the second try guys only on
the second try
can hardly believe it
wow would you look at that all right
well that was elden ring good game
honestly i really liked that game that
was very fun i was a bit short um bit
short but you know honestly i think that
i had a great time with this game
uh very fun you can check out for
yourself
uh and you can look in the link in the
description below for the cloak elden
ring collab uh glad i was able to beat
this one i thought this was going to be
one another one of those games that i
just start and don't finish and then
everyone's like oh mark please you gotta
you gotta know you gotta beat it but i'm
glad that i can like check this one off
the list i've beaten the game fully and
completely honestly a hundred percent
and i i very rarely hundred 100 games
these days anymore just don't have the
time but i like a nice succinct
experience
one that you can really sink your teeth
into feel accomplished about
i feel proud of myself i'll feel proud
of myself and you'll feel proud of
yourself if you go to cloakbrand.com
you can check out the elden ring cloak
collab
they're waiting for you all this gilded
gear
the gilded clothes the
the guilt the gilded clothing
the tarnished oh i'm sorry sorry my arm
just does that sometimes you see you see
you see the though i'm pointing at the
words there but you see that i'll show
you on on this side too
oh i apologize just sometimes that
happens but you know you can see right
there and you know right there yeah so
check it out cloakbrand.com link in the
description thank you everybody so much
for watching
try eldon ring for yourself a nice short
experience that everyone can get behind
and everyone can enjoy
link in the description if you don't
click it
i'll know
so you better click it
link
is in the description
i'll know
and i'm watching you
so you better click that link in the
description